[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to every damn day
today we're gonna be talking about three
Nathan for you solutions that we would
actually like to use in our life joining
us today is Tim Barnes at Tim Barnes 451
at Han sticky at Jordy pizza I am at I
am Ryan Beck so Nathan fielder has like
so many crazy ideas on Nathan for you
and they're all so funny and but what's
crazy is that like actually some of them
have worked like the dumb Starbucks one
for instance was like there was real
stores and they had Starbucks actually
had to put out a statement about the
store and they couldn't stop it because
of parody law which was like what I was
trying to kind of like expose and like
point out but what's so great is that
the reason that they did get shut down
was for health code so ultimately dumb
Starbucks is no more but there are like
so many other great products that he's
invented so this episode we're gonna be
talking about at least three times I
think three I think we're only allowed
to play three Clips yeah three times
that Nathan fielder's business plans
actually might be genius Jordan which
which one did you think was like the
sharpest well I definitely laugh maybe
the hardest at the sex box thing but I'm
thinking about it whenever like I
sometimes do you have sex guys whatever
I might say in the graduation I do have
sex so please stop saying that I've been
seeing it on other videos for some
reason I wish I could put my neighbor's
in a sex box beak so that they wouldn't
be able to hear when I want to do it cuz
it's a little private I'm a private
person but the sex box is basically a
device Nathan fielder in fact invented
for parents to put their children in so
that they can have intercourse and their
children aren't gonna be mentally
disturbed by oh my god
watch and learn huh
making me beg for that don't shoot your
again after a few minutes the real
Jurgen and Marie decided to leave the
room okay with Jurgen and Marie gone I
was left to monitor the rest of the test
on my own
once I observed the couple had climaxed
I knew it wasn't gonna get any louder so
I had them finish up and brought in
something comfortable for them to put on
and with Holly and Tony out of the room
it was time to see if my box had worked
so what was it like being in outer space
fun it's their time when you guys felt
like you really wanted a sex box for
like someone like you maybe you're
making a bunch of noise or something
maybe you ask you so lesson we had sex
though I mean like sometimes you have
quiet sex do stupi to be like boots
or something like that like or like jrue
certain pH you only have to change a
couple letters well I mean like public
place sex is very like a high-risk
high-reward kind of thing and that kind
of brings us to your clip I think is
there's like a very high risk reward
thing this clip is my favorite because
Nathan fielder learns a trick on how to
undo handcuffs and then to make sure he
can do it he puts himself in front of a
bunch of kids with a robot that will
expose him if he can't get his hands for
any time hi he'll become a sex offender
if he doesn't do it there's a police
officer on site the button is a kill
switch it is the only thing that can
stop the program the motion of the robot
from taking off Nathan's pants in front
of these kids and now he will deliver
the line given to him by Judge Filosa
something might happen here and if it
does so what and with that he has
established willful intent so if he
exposes himself tonight in the eyes of
the law it will not be considered in a
state well Jordan for his New Year's
resolution he said he was gonna post
once a day or he'd get a Logan Paul and
Jay Paul tattoo like right here Wow like
sort of a classic mom thing so like
right there I never really heard this
sad yeah where's the cat dog anyway
first he did not do any post
and I said 40 I'm really focused on my
mental health now we need that every
damned ambition to shame Jordan into
getting this time when she did promise
us - was it like your resolution it was
your idea for the whole thing yeah I
thought it was really funny yeah but now
you have to get this essay now speaking
of tattoos I did get a tattoo Oh last
night you know what
show me your commitment show me that
you're gonna commit your life to me yes
sir I was there yesterday when you're
debating not going on this date he did
last night yes after because I was hurt
yeah we didn't even kiss where's the
tattoo man what's it say I should just
show it oh yeah SN m which is Smith and
mill which is the bar we met at that was
closed for a party but you know it's oh
my god wait you didn't even that's not
even the bar that you had your one glass
of wine before making this decision yeah
the bar was closed but you decided to
tattoo the name of that bar
okay we're talking about we have dumb
tattoos and I was like we should go get
live right now he's like let's go that
guy he was a risk manager yeah this is
like the ultimate miscalculation what
were the last moments of the day that's
what I'm interested okay so our last
clip I'm gonna do this really high power
transition now it's about frozen yogurt
and poop bring it home baby so why this
one it's in the first season it's the
first one that I saw that really caught
my attention and I just think it's a
great idea because I love marketing so
the idea is that like people don't like
this frozen yogurt so let's make one
flavor that is poop it's not that people
don't like the frozen yogurt it's just
that the frozen yogurt store needs to
draw more people in yeah yeah and so
that's the gimmick is the best a gimmick
yeah yeah this is what you requested we
call it artificial feces flavor emulsion
is there a real there's no actual it's
completely edible it you could eat this
right but if you wanted to do this it
into yogurt you you could make yogurt I
didn't want to be the first to try it
but I needed to know if the taste was
accurate
so I conducted a taste test with some
stranger's so I'd like everyone to try
the frozen yogurt in front of you
think about this what's happening do you
have some foot
what is Harry Potter Bertie Botts beans
oh yeah every flavor yeah players on
that puppy you carried this in your
pocket for the express purpose of like
oh wait let me read the flavors first we
have earwax earthworm dirt cinnamon
cherry candy floss booger blueberry
black pepper and banana but it also
tells you which ones which yeah like
what's the just do a roulette and I
don't want to do it here's the thing
it's a mix of flavors you're not
supposed to eat the booger alone you
supposed to eat it with maybe a little
berry or something just like you do with
frozen yogurt right close your eyes and
open your hands absolutely not
which one is this I think it's booger I
think I got booger I give me one ring
I'm almost 100% sure that I got booger
tell me that's not polka I got a I got a
yellow one that might be pea right that
might be earwax okay I'm gonna put its
banana how are we all doing it there's
like Church that marshmallow pretty good
I don't know I'm not sure if I like bug
or not
yeah it's kind of good right I think
with the let the poo ice cream yeah oh
yeah I got banana great yeah I'm eating
booger it's not bad that's like
peppermint what do you do
maybe a bombing oh my god oh maybe it's
earthworm okay Mike it might just hey
everybody thank you for watching every
damn day check out extra damn day on
Twitter we're there every single day and
we really appreciate you watching Thanks
[Music]
you